hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in categories chapter 11 Aristotle is
examining really three main topics all
of which add to our understanding of
contraries tanaan Tia in the Greek and
remember contraries are one of four main
types of opposition that he discusses
contraries are particularly important
when we're thinking about qualities
because that tends to be where they they
fall in and so in the first little
discussion he talks about the contrary
of good being evil or bad so we have
Augusta's and and Agathon rather and
kakoen those are the greek terms and so
he says you can prove this by induction
we're not really going to worry too much
about that induction is epic okay and
there's a whole interesting discussion
about what that consists in what we're
really after here is that aristotle
points out something that might seem to
be an exception to the rule which is
that a contrary only has one thing that
is opposed to it now that's not going to
be the case in most contraries but it is
with bad and good how is it the case
with bad and good well here is where we
see Aristotle relying on some
understanding of his virtue ethics where
he points out that what is good tends to
be a mean or middle metal case in Greek
between two extremes so the contrary of
a bad can be a good or it can be
something else that's bad in the case of
virtues and vices right the mean is what
is good and the things that are bad are
at the ends the defect or the excess you
know for example when it comes to
enjoyment of bodily pleasure
there's too much of that and too strong
of a desire for that and uncontrolled
desire that's bad but also not having
desire at all a defect in that that's
also bad so if we ask well what is the
bad opposed to it could be understood as
being opposed to the good which is the
middle position the virtue say of
temperance or moderation or it could be
opposed to the vice that's at the other
extreme so that is one very important
point right there about the the nature
of contrary some contraries may in fact
have multiple things that they're
opposed to right now that that's one
interesting topic the second really
interesting topic it has to do with
contrast we might say Aristotle raises a
question if one contrary exists does
that mean that the other one of
necessity must exist and here's where we
want to look at some of the examples
that he provides he tells us it does not
have necessity follow that if one of
these countries exists the other must
exist so when people are saying well you
know you can't have the good without the
bad or things along those lines
Aristotle would say that's not really
correct at all you can't have the good
health of bad right
so he says considered healthiness
suppose that all things became healthy
then there would be health not disease
or suppose that all things became white
then all things would be white only not
black and is this imaginable yes it is
you I mean it would be hard to figure
out how to get around in a world where
everything was white because we'd have
no visual contrast I suppose unless we
had shades of white but imagine a world
in which everyone was healthy and no
disease existed that's feasible so just
because one contrary exists doesn't mean
the other one has to exist he goes on
and he says you know in as much as
Socrates ill is the country of Socrates
well in both countries cannot exist at
the same time in the same individual if
one of the contraries existed than the
other
did not then exist for provided he was
well was the fact he was ill could not
also be the fact he's reducing he's
trying to make an argument here by
reducing it to one thing that would have
that quality but we don't have to go
that way we could imagine an entire
world in which everything became good or
everything became sour or everything
became whatever contraries we want it
would be possible for that to be the
case Aristotle thinks the last thing has
to do with genus and species and here it
starts to become a bit more abstract and
you can say well what what is he talking
about here we'll use some examples that
will help flush this out so he says that
the subject of contrary qualities
contraries must have the same species or
genus what are we talking about there
well the subjects remember are the
things in which these qualities these
contrary qualities exist so I could be
healthy or sick I am the subject and
health or sickness is the contrary
quality right which I which I possess I
can be old or young right I can be good
or bad as a person and you know remember
there's contraries that have gradations
and all of that we don't have to worry
about that here what we're interested in
is when we're talking about these terms
like say good and bad or healthy or sick
we're interested in not just a subject
but multiple subjects and those multiple
subjects must be either in the same
species a human being right you're a
human being presumably watching this or
they have to be in the same genus so
let's take one with species first using
the example that Aristotle provides he
talks about goodness and badness right
moral goodness and badness and
in the sentence and where does that
exist it exists in as he says in the
souls of human beings so if justice
exists in my soul and injustice exists
in your soul or if I change from being
just to unjust right then where justice
is the subject that it in here's within
is in the same species because you are
the same species as me what about health
and sickness there we're talking about
Genesis might be animal or even living
thing right health and sickness don't
exist say in rocks I mean we can talk in
a metaphorical sense about the health of
a faultline or something like that but
we're being very metaphorical there when
we're talking about health and sickness
per se those apply to things within a
particular genus that of living things
so Aristotle uses those exact examples
but also white and black belong to the
same genus as he's going to tell us
whiteness and black does belong to
bodies those don't have to be living
right so so when you're talking about
genus is at a very high level physical
objects for example these are often
geniuses that incorporate other geniuses
but there's still genesis in aristotle
schema there's another connected
corollary or topic here as well
contraries themselves can they be said
to belong to species and Genesis well a
contrary in a certain sense is already a
species it's naming a set of things that
have something in common so if we talk
about white things and black things or
purple things right and brown things
those belong to a particular genus all
right
the genus of color
and we can also have things belonging to
contrary geniuses Aristotle gives an
example of this he says good justice and
injustice fall under two contrary genera
that of virtue and vice so virtue vice
those are the high-level abstractions
here particulars justice courage
temperance particular voice --is
injustice cowardice in temperance right
those are species of things which are
then just you know this is just this
person is just this arrangement is just
those relate to that that species and
then that species relates to a genus the
genus of vice he goes on and he says
good and evil themselves do not belong
to any genera
why not because they are themselves
actual genera or Genesis they they are
what other things fall under so these
are some important additional
clarifications to keep in mind with
respect to one particular kind of
opposition that is contraries